- Good morning, everyone.
Welcome to the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean here at the
Institute and I'm
so glad to have you all here
on this beautiful sunny day,
finally.
At the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study
we support and convene scholars,
policy makers, scientists,
and artists from
all around the world
to work across disciplines
and at the forefront
of their fields.
And we are committed to
sharing that knowledge
and thought provoking discussion
with a broad and interested
public.
In order to do that, Radcliffe
offers a full calendar
of public events
throughout the year,
including lectures, exhibitions,
seminars, conferences,
and more.
For example, right now you
can visit an exhibition
at the Schlesinger
Library entitled,
"Playing Fair, Title IX at 45,"
which displays photographs,
video, and archival materials
to tell the story of women
athletes before and after the
landmark legislation of Title
IX.
The exhibition can be found two
doors down from this building
at the Schlesinger library
and it will be up until June.
It's open all day and you can
visit during lunch or breaks
today.
Later this spring, we'll
continue the exploration
of title IX's legacy and
its impact with a panel
discussion co-hosted with WBUR.
And featuring Maura Healy,
who brings her experience,
not only as Massachusetts's
Attorney General, but as
a former basketball player.
Many people may not know
that Maura co-captained
the basketball team at
Harvard as an undergraduate
before going on to play
professional basketball
in Austria.
Maura will be joined by Olympic
ice hockey medalist, Angela
Ruggiera, and Boston Globe and
WBUR sports reporter, Shira
Springer for a probing
discussion on the progress
we have made towards
gender equality in sports
as well as the obstacles
that still remain.
That panel will take place
on Tuesday, May 16th at 7:00
PM, right here in
the Knafel Center,
and you can register
on our website.
And finally, on Friday, May
26th our spring programming
will culminate in Radcliffe
day, an annual celebration
of Radcliffe's past,
present, and future.
Each year on this day we
award the Radcliffe medal
to a person who has had
a transformative impact
on society.
This year we will
honor two women
who have made a profound mark
on the field of journalism,
Judy Woodruff and
the late Gwen Eiffel.
That day long event
is an opportunity
to honor Judy and Gwen's
groundbreaking accomplishments,
both as a team and
as individuals.
It will include a
panel discussion
to probe the challenges
facing journalism today.
Please visit the
Radcliffe website
for more information
on the day and how you
can obtain tickets to attend.
Today we are gathered for
Radcliffe's annual gender
conference.
Each year we examine an issue
such as violence, immigration,
or the evolving use of language
through the lens of gender.
Such complex topics require
an interdisciplinary approach,
which we will bring
to bear today,
drawing on the expertise
of coaches, CEOs, athletes,
journalists, and a neurologist,
just to name a few.
A conference like this one
is only possible with lots
of help and support.
I'd like to take a
moment to thank everyone
who has made today a reality.
First, thank you to our
supporters, many of whom
are with us today.
Your generosity
allows us to ensure
that events like this one remain
free and open to the public.
Thank you for your participation
in our annual fund.
Thank you as well to the faculty
organizers at this conference,
Janet Rich-Edwards
and Yukio Lippit,
who worked with Executive
Director of Academic
Ventures, Rebecca
Wasserman, and her team
to organize today's event.
Thank you to the members
of our hardworking planning
committee including Sean
O'Donnell, Susan Ware, and Ceri
Blauwet.
And thank you to the performers
at last night's art event
as well as to the former
fellows, Lydia Diamond
and Martha Ackmann,
whose collaboration
brought that wonderful
performance to life.
And thank you to the many
professors, coaches, students,
and Harvard
community members who
gathered last
spring to brainstorm
for this conference
with us, and they
held associated events
all year long related
to today's conference.
And finally, thanks
to all of you
who are coming here
today for this conference
from as near as Harvard
Yard, and as far away
as Atlanta, San Francisco,
and Lubbock, Texas.
We also welcome many people
from around the world
who will be viewing
our conference online.
It's exciting for us to see
such an enthusiastic response
to this year's topic
from so many corners.
One reason for
such great interest
in a conference about
sports and gender
is that the topic is both
very timely and timeless.
Its current relevance
is all around us.
Athletic teams at Harvard and
at many other universities
this year have had to confront
troubling demonstrations
of demeaning attitudes
towards female athletes.
Just last week, the
US women's hockey team
made the news when they struck
an unprecedented deal with USA
hockey for higher wages.
All it took was the
threat of a boycott,
15 months of tense
negotiations, and an open letter
from 16 US senators.
The questions raised by
the intersection of gender
and sports are certainly
newsworthy today,
but those questions
have been present
around the world
for much of history.
Early artwork from ancient
Egypt to medieval Europe
featured male and
female human figures
swinging at balls with sticks.
But despite their
widespread appearance
across many times and places,
neither sports nor gender
are unchanging.
Both are shaped by social,
political, economic,
and cultural context.
Let me give you an example.
In the early decades of
the 19th century, sports
we're actually regarded
poorly in Western society.
Games were all very well for
children, but for adults sports
were morally suspect.
Men who aspired
social respectability
rejected popular sports
like prizefighting
as vulgar and overly physical
pastimes of the lower classes.
But by the
mid-nineteenth century,
things began to change
with new movement called
muscular Christianity.
Beginning in England and
spreading to the Northeastern
United States,
muscular Christianity
equated physical fitness
with moral health,
and linked both to masculinity.
In order for members
of the upper class,
both men and women,
to claim sports
as elite and respectable,
however, sports
had to be repackaged from
a rough and tumble pastime
into an activity
befitting gentlemen.
And it wasn't an
easy shift to make.
As late as 1859,
Harper's Magazine
insisted that grown adults
who indulged in sports
must be either, and I
quote, "milksops or bad me."
How then, did proponent's
of athleticism
finally legitimize men's
participation in sports?
Promoters of sporting
events began inviting women
to sports games in an effort
to infuse those events
with the values of Victorian
womanhood such as refinement,
delicacy, and propriety.
Team owners provided special
tents and refreshments
for women spectators, and
women assumed specific roles
such as presenting bouquets or
game balls to winning teams.
For sports to become
more respectable for men,
both men and women
took on new roles.
Of course, in 1860, women's
roles were decidedly limited.
They could attend games.
They could bestow
flowers on winners.
They could even play
a number of sports,
so long as they
didn't keep score.
As for competing, only men were
supposed to do that for fear
that competition might
make women too coarse.
It should be clear that
sports provide a powerful lens
for understanding
much larger questions
of an historical
time, and sports
continue to offer that
similar critical lens today.
Now as then, sport
and gender are
inseparable from each other.
Now as then, gender disparity
is a major characteristic
of sports.
Today, women compete,
but not on equal footing.
Even in tennis, the sport
lauded for coming closest to pay
equity, discrepancies remain.
In 2015, Roger Federer won the
men's Western and Southern open
and received more than $700,000.
Just hours later, Serena
Williams, arguably
the world's most outstanding
athlete, won the women's title
and she collected a prize
of less than $500,000.
If inequities between men
and women have persisted,
in other ways the relationship
between sport and gender
has changed over time.
We now face questions
about steroid use
and athletic performance,
neurological damage
while competing, and the rights
of transgender participants.
These questions and more require
an interdisciplinary approach
capable of considering the many
complexities of gender, sports,
and society.
That is what brings
us all here today.
I just want to say
before we move on
that we want to treat
you to a reception
at the end of the
day at Fei House
to celebrate our
panelists and organizers.
So I look forward to
talking with you then.
It is now my pleasure
to turn things over
to Susan Ware, who will
moderate the first panel.
Susan is an acclaimed
historian and the biographer
of such notable figures as
Billie Jean King and Amelia
Earhart, as well as the
editor of the latest
volume of Notable
American Women,
a biographical dictionary.
Susan currently serves as
general editor of the American
National Biography and she
is also the honorary Women's
Suffrage Centennial Historian
at the Schlesinger Library,
here at Radcliffe.
Please join me in
welcoming Susan Ware.
[APPLAUSE]
- Good morning.
Thanks so much for coming and
very glad to have you here.
This session is organized around
a seemingly straightforward
question, who gets to play?
Yet like many of
the other issues
we'll be discussing today,
the answer is far from simple,
and certainly not static.
Our main focus is on
what role gender plays
in access to
sports, but we can't
address that in isolation.
So we'll also be
exploring questions
of race, class, sexual
identity, and disability.
We want to think carefully
about which sports
we're talking about,
recreational sports,
high school or
college athletics,
international competitions,
or professional leagues.
We want to explore how the
United States system conforms
to or differs from how sport
is organized around the world.
We want to think about special
challenges to sports access.
How can an athlete compete
in international competition
if she's a stateless refugee
or cannot find the appropriate
athletic gear to accommodate
her religious beliefs.
We won't necessarily be able
to cover all of those topics,
but we certainly
hope that we will
start conversations
that will continue
for the rest of the day.
So in many ways,
in certain ways,
this is the history panel.
We're exploring how the
question, who gets to play,
has changed over time, and
how this historical trajectory
might influence who's
next in staking a claim.
So it seems
especially appropriate
that it's taking place in the
former Radcliffe gymnasium.
One glorious summer
afternoon several years
ago, I snuck into the
building in my running gear,
and I ran 16 laps, a mile,
around the upper level track.
And as I circled the gym,
I felt a literal connection
through the floorboards
to the generations
of Radcliffe athletes who
had also run on that track.
What must they
think, I wondered,
of the opportunities available
to female athletes today.
Opportunities that would
have been inconceivable
in their time, indeed
inconceivable probably
to certain members
of this audience.
And yet-- and there's
always that catch--
so much has happened, especially
in the last five decades,
and yet women athletes are
still nowhere near anything
approaching gender
equity in athletics.
So drawing up a balance sheet
between the undisputed progress
in widening access versus the
ongoing structural and societal
barriers to full
participation will
be a recurring theme
of our panel, indeed,
of the whole conference.
And it's especially
relevant to take stock
as Title IX, the US law that
played such an important part
in fostering the revolution
in women's sports,
turns 45 this year,
which is a plug
to visit the exhibit,
Documentary [INAUDIBLE] History
at the Schlesinger library.
So now it's time
to hear about who
gets to play from our stellar
panel who's full biographies
are in the program.
But I am delighted to share the
stage with Donna Lopiano, who
is the former CEO of the
Women's Sports Foundation,
one of my favorite
groups, and now president
of Sports Management Resources.
With Anita DeFrantaz, a longtime
member of the International
Olympic Committee, and boy
I'm sure she could tell us
stories about that, and a
bronze medalist in rowing
at the 1976 Olympics.
And Stephanie Wheeler,
a 2004 and 2008
Paralympics gold medalist in
women's wheelchair basketball,
who now coaches at the
University of Illinois.
So after their
presentations, the panelists
will spend some time
talking among themselves
about common concerns,
and potential points
of disagreement, and then we'll
open the floor to questions.
So with that, I just have to
say, let the game changers
games begin.
[APPLAUSE]
- So, it's my job in
this first 15 minutes
to give you the
history of Title IX.
From 30,000 feet,
give you a sense
of what the current statistics
are and to answer the question,
how close are we
to gender equity?
And then I want to take a
view from ground zero look
at Harvard's athletic program.
Wherever I go to speak,
I always make sure
that the home team gets
my attention, for sure.
So let me see if this works.
OK, so, this is quick and dirty.
Research shows that the
faster the speaker speaks,
the greater the
retention of the audience
because you can't fall asleep.
I learned that when I
went to my first job
at the University of Texas.
Everybody was kind of
scary in terms of Yankee
speed of speech.
Anyway, I've always
I've always referred
to the civil rights laws in
the US as the perfect trifecta.
They all use the same language,
whether it's the Civil Rights
Act of 1964, or Title IX of
the 1972 education amendments,
or the Rehabilitation
Act of 1973,
followed by the
Disabilities Act of '93,
it's all the same language.
If you are receiving
federal funds,
you cannot discriminate on
the basis of, and then fill
in the blank.
Very simple law.
Nobody knew it applied to
intercollegiate athletics
until the law firm,
the Washington D.C law
firm the NCAA asked the
question, in early 1974,
does it apply to
extracurricular activities?
And the answer was
then yes, but you
should know that Title IX
was never an athletics law.
It was fully intended
by Edith Green and Birch
Bayh, who were the co-sponsors
of the original law,
it was fully intended
to open the doors
of professional graduate
education to women.
It was an Equal Pay
Act issue at the time
that they realized that women
couldn't get paid more if they
didn't have advanced degrees.
And there were
quotas on the number
of women who were admitted
into medical school, who
were admitted into law
school, who became engineers.
If your father didn't
build a building,
you didn't get
into those programs
because they were afraid you
were going to have babies,
and your education would
be absolutely wasted.
But anyway, so the
NCAA in 1974 says,
does this law apply to
intercollegiate athletics
and extracurricular activities?
The answer is yes and
all hell breaks loose.
Darrell Royal, who is then
the president of the American
Football Coaches Association
was quoted across the country
as "Title IX of
women's athletics
would be the death of big
time football as we know it."
Horrors, horrors to be.
And one of the great things
about the entry of the football
establishment was that it was
the invitation to the media
to equally cover the issue.
If Darrell said
this about what was
going to happen
to football, what
were the women going
to say in terms
of the effect of Title IX?
And the leaders of women's
athletics at the time
were female physical educators.
Well-educated,
they've researched
the impact of sport
participation on girls,
and they hit the media
with a salvo of research
supported fact that to this
day has never been rivaled.
They were quick.
They didn't attack football.
They were just
simply saying, guess
what, girls who play sports
are less likely to experience
sexual harassment, are less
likely to get a heart attack.
They just listed all the
physiological benefits
of sport.
Psychologically, they
have stronger self-images.
They have higher levels
of competence, confidence,
they are more likely to
succeed in life after sport.
And the end question was
hey, sport does great things
for your son and your daughter.
Do you want your son and
daughter to be treated equally?
And the answer was
a resounding yes.
So this benefits to
girls media message
wielded by fact supporting--
I know you haven't heard that
recently-- fact supporting
women in the business
really made a dent in terms
of public sentiment, and you
can see what the figures are
in terms of the percentage
of the public that
is in support of Title
IX, even if it means
lost opportunities for men.
And then the last point
to be made, historically,
is it really was a
father led movement.
Mom never had the
chance to play sports.
Dad all of a sudden had
a single point of contact
with surrogate son.
My daughter is playing sports.
I can have a catch with
her in the backyard
and the biggest advocates
of sport became fathers.
And it was this
father-mother combo
that really has been
responsible for the staying
power of the law.
Let me mention one more
piece of this puzzle.
There was an accident
in history that
ensured that Title IX could
never be tampered with,
and that accident was when
the football coaches made
their stink.
Congress responded
by saying well,
we'll make sure that the
regulations interpreting
the law's application
to sport get
issued before the law goes
into effect so everybody
knows what the game's about.
That never happens
to regulations.
Usually a law
passes, it's debated
in the courts for
10 years, and then
regulations eventually evolve.
In this case, tons
of regulations
on the application of title
IX, specific to sports,
were issued, and every
single court case
has deferred to
those regulations.
And you don't have any of the
disagreements in the court that
typically follow the passage
of a new law like this.
And I think that
accident of history
is singularly responsible for
the stability of Title IX.
All right, the view from
30,000 feet-- and I'm
going to go through
this stuff very quickly.
When you look at
high school sports,
you're looking at
in 1971 and '72.
Men having about 3.6
million opportunities
to play compared to
294,000 for women.
What is interesting is when you
look at it in '14-'15, the last
available data.
Women at the high
school level still
have not achieved the
participation levels
that men had in 1971.
They are still 1.1 million
opportunities short
from matching up
to their proportion
in the general student body.
One thing this data shows
us is that it has not
been a zero sum game.
The fears that the football
coaches and everybody
else expressed
with Title IX where
oh, if you give women the
chance to play then they're
going to take opportunities
away from your son.
And you can see from this
data that it never happened.
Men's participation
and boys participation
has continued to grow at the
high school and the college
level.
It has not been a zero sum
game, and interestingly,
over the last decade,
men's participation
has grown at a quicker rate.
More opportunities
have been added for men
than have been added for women,
despite the fact that women
are still under-represented
in high school sports.
The picture at the
college level is the same.
It's almost identical.
So you're looking at numbers
in '72-'73 versus '14-'15.
At the college level, 57% of
all college undergraduates
are female.
Only 43% of all
athletes are female.
And same animal in terms
of more opportunities
have been added for men
in the last 10 years
than have been added for female.
So instead of this
gap getting smaller,
which it started to do in
the first 30 years or so,
it's now starting
to peel apart again.
So the gap is greater.
So why is this happening?
Right?
As the wrestling
coaches will tell you,
every time a wrestling
program is dropped
it's because of Title IX.
Men's sports are suffering
because of what's
happening for women, with
women, and the answer
is just the opposite.
What is happening
is that men's sports
are getting dropped
so that money
can shift to fund the arms race
in football and basketball.
And you can tell because
men have been growing
more than women, and women
are still not close to equity,
and nothing's been done
over the last 10 years.
You can tell that's
true, but you can also
tell from this chart.
If you look at that bright
yellow 328 up there,
this shows you the net gain
and loss of sport programs
for men and women.
You can't just look
at drop programs.
We add and drop
sports all the time.
In the 70s women
didn't play soccer.
Men didn't play soccer
in this country.
We sure didn't play lacrosse.
We were playing badminton.
We we're playing field hockey.
So sports change all the time.
So you have to look at what
the net gains and losses are.
So you can see that in women's
sports, it's always net gains.
In men's sport, in Division
two and three, which
are the least financially
supported sports,
in Division two and three,
men's sports continue to grow.
Division one, the richest
programs in the United States
are the ones that
are dropping sports,
and they're doing it
to fuel this arms race.
If you look at the percentage
of the men's sport budgets
that go to just
these two sports,
and knowing that Division one is
the highest competitive level,
you're looking at FBS, the
college football playoff,
81% of the men's sports
budgets among these 125 FBS
institutions, 81% percent
go to just those two sports.
And the number that really
kills me on this chart
is look at Division 1, no
football, third row down.
Right, Division 1, no football.
So there's no football
players, zero.
There's just men's basketball.
And men's basketball,
those 12 players
are getting 44% of the
men's operating budget.
So have no doubt that why this
is happening in terms of men's
non-revenue sports
being dropped.
This is a quick and dirty in
terms of the financial support
of men's versus women's sports.
Title IX does not
require equal dollars.
It doesn't.
But if you look at the money
picture, follow the money,
you can see there's smoke
here, and where there's smoke,
there's usually fire.
And this gives you a good idea
of how poorly women's sports
are still supported in
every single division.
Yes, football is more
expensive than other sports,
but when you look at
these of funding gaps--
I testify in Title IX
lawsuits all the time.
Believe me, there are
very few institutions
in this country that are in
compliance with Title IX.
Media coverage of women's
sports-- and Mike Messner,
I love Mike Messner, is going
to speak on this later on.
So I'm not going to
spend time on this.
But fortunately, we have--
Mike, is it still true that
we are getting more coverage
than the horses and dogs?
[CHUCKLES]
- Unless the horses
and dogs are being used
to make fun of women's sports.
- I got it.
But seriously, horse
racing and dog racing
used to be covered
more than women.
I think we might
have surpassed that.
Newspaper coverage is
a function of what does
a sports editor want to see.
What does the sports editor
want his writers to write about.
Sports editors do
not take surveys
and see what the public wants.
So we don't have very
many women or people
of color, for that
matter, in sports editors.
You can see that
in our coverage.
When you look at college
sports leadership,
this is where the real
crimes are being wrought.
You're looking at
roughly 80% of--
I don't care whether
you pick coaches,
athletic directors,
administrators, 80%
are white males.
And that's a large statement.
But roughly, that's
about what it is.
And these numbers are
worse for persons of color.
So you can see that in
terms of employment,
Title IX has not had a
concomitant effect on women
in terms of employment.
Now, the view from
ground zero, and I know
you don't have glasses, OK so--
and these are very
small numbers,
but I want you to look
at the last column only.
OK?
This is the female participation
gap at each of the Ivy League
institutions.
So that is the number of women's
participation opportunities
that need to be added
for women to comprise
their percentage in these
respective student bodies.
So I've kept men's
participation constant
and just did a simple
mathematical formula.
So as you can see,
Harvard is only 122
shy in terms of
having to do something
more for women's sports.
So I'm here to tell
you that Harvard is not
in compliance with Title IX.
But why don't I end with that.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well done.
- Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Anita DeFrantz and
I come from points beyond.
I was just in
Denmark where there
was a gathering of all the
international federations
of the world that are part
of the Olympic movement.
And this is important to
us because, in many senses,
the Olympic movement has
kept sports alive worldwide,
not intentionally.
And certainly, people know that
Pierre de Coubertin wasn't that
much of a fan of women's sport.
In fact, he's quoted as saying
that the purpose for women
is to applaud politely the man
as they endeavor through sport.
To his credit, he
never prohibited women
from competing.
He never put up a rope.
He just did not support it much.
I wanted you to
get a sense for how
the Olympic movement has grown.
Sports opportunities
have grown and I
hope you can see it
better than I can.
You'll see that in
the year 19,000,
the number of sports
for women were two,
the number of national
Olympic committees were five,
and the number of
participants were 22.
As you go down,
eventually you'll
get to the Olympic
Winter sports,
when that lighter color is--
boy, that's really
hard for you to read.
I'm sorry.
The lighter color is
added, then you have
both the Olympic Winter Games.
Look at 1924, both
the Olympic Winter
Games and the Olympic games.
Very modest number.
The men's numbers are not
that much more significantly,
but over time, slowly but
surely we have more numbers,
and that means across
the world, if we
were to put up the numbers
of women competitors
from the United
States, it would be
much larger than any other
country, for which I am proud.
I then learned that
by the year 2000
there were fewer than 2000 women
who had represented the United
States at the Olympic games,
which is such a tiny number.
The numbers will get larger
because we needed to do that.
Still, this gives you a
snapshot of the numbers
of women competing at the games
throughout modern time, which
for us, started in 1900.
Now this one-- percentage
is also important.
The percentage of
events for women because
at a certain point women had a
better chance at winning medals
than men did, mathematically,
because there were actually
more events for women,
and a smaller number
of women competing,
and that helped
the national Olympic
committee to recognize
that they could be more
successful if only they
were to support their women,
and they could go home
with more medals.
Now, I didn't announce
this too loudly,
but we kept putting the numbers
up, and they finally got that.
And indeed, you'll note
starting in at least 19--
I'm sorry, starting
in 2008, '12, and '16,
many of the larger teams
had more women than men.
And Indeed, the mighty
nation Bhutan had no men,
but only had women on their
Olympic team in Rio de Janeiro.
You start seeing that
there is a recognition
that your country can be made
proud by having women athletes.
When one of the goals of
the IOC, since our Congress
in 1994--
Congress means we bring together
not just this International
Olympic Committee, our annual
meeting is called the Session.
But we bring together along
with IOC members, the National
Olympic Committee members.
There are now 206 National
That's more members
than there are
members of the United Nation.
In part because Puerto Rico
has its own National Olympic
Committee and others who
would not necessarily
be recognized by the UN
as separate countries.
So there are more NOCs
than there are countries
for historical reasons.
And we also, for the games
in Rio, created something
called the refugee team.
We recognized that there
are people in these refugee
camps, some of whom have
been there for decades,
and we wanted the
young people who've
grown up there to have a
chance to be Olympians.
[APPLAUSE]
So the first ever refugee
team competed in Rio.
And by the way, we don't
just say OK, great.
Thanks for coming.
You competed, you did well, bye.
We stay with those
members of the team.
We help them get placed.
We help them develop
the skills they
need to get back into
society and some of them
are continuing to compete.
So moving on, I wanted
you to see the overall--
the curve.
And you'll see that the men are
continually on an upward swing,
but that's the total number
of athletes at the games.
And the women start to
go up, and up, and up.
Just quickly, from
1900 to 1984, there
were about 12,000 women who
competed at the Olympic games.
From 1988 to 2016,
there have been
over 30,000 women who have
competed at the Olympic games.
Which to me, says that there
is a large cadre of women
available to give back, who
are of the proper age group
to be able to give
their time, and take
on positions of leadership.
The IOC has made it
clear that we believe--
if you can believe
that we believe this--
that the world is made
up of at least 50% women,
probably more, but
at least 50% women,
and therefore the number
of athletes at the games
should reflect the
world, and the number
of positions in
leadership should likewise
reflect the world.
Studies have been done
throughout the world that
show that boards of
directors that are equally
made up of women and men,
what a shock, equality means--
none of this equity
stuff for me, equality.
Those boards do
a much better job
of leading their organizations.
They're much more successful
than other boards.
So if you know of any boards
they are predominantly made up
of one sex other than
the other, you can just
tell them they would do better
if they would get their act
together and even it out.
It's all for the better.
That's what we want to do.
We want to make things better.
So, you can see from this chart
that slowly, far too slowly,
but certainly, we're
moving towards equality
at the Olympic games.
One other thing that happened.
As we move towards
more equality,
we noticed that the reporting
at the Olympic games
became proportionate.
In other words, if
your team was made up
of 40% men and 60% women,
the reporting on the games
was made up of 60% women
stories and 40% male stories.
I don't know how the
journalists do that,
but it followed that trend,
which is even more compelling
to have equal numbers of
athletes, men and women
in the game so we can get
equal number of reporting.
And the remarkable thing is
they can do it for two weeks
during the games.
I think you can
probably do it forever
if you really wanted to.
It works.
So we need to get
people understanding
that it does work
and the world will
be a better place when we get
more of the stories out there.
OK, the next slide has
to do with the new sports
on the program.
There are new sports
on the program
and that is one messed up chart.
I'm sorry.
Where it says year, just put
the zero over so it's 1900.
1994, things like that.
So you can do that.
You guys are at Radcliffe.
You can move the
chart, move the column.
And you see how long it took
to get some of the sports
on the programme, which
is really amazing.
1976, which were
the great games--
yes, that's when I competed.
There we go.
1976, go!
Yeah!
Finally, rowing, basketball.
Did you realize that
women's basketball was not
on the program of the
Olympic games until 1976?
Then it goes much faster as
we move along from that point
and the games in London
was the first games when
all the sports on the
program had women's events.
It took us from--
let's see, 1896 to 2012
to get all of the sports
on the program for
men, for women.
It's often pointed out to
me that men do not take part
in synchronized swimming.
Not true.
At the Fino World Championships,
it was a mixed event.
And the gentleman who all
those many years ago complained
bitterly that he was
not allowed to compete,
his duet actually won
the world championships
in mixed synchronized swimming.
I've lost his name, but I'm sure
Twitter, Google, or somebody
can find his name for you.
So, yes, synchronized
swimming has found its way
to making opportunities
for men and women.
It's important to
know that there are
sports that continue to go on.
In the Olympic
Winter Games we were
coming very close to parity,
then new sports came on,
and I will confess I was
asleep at the switch.
I was no longer in charge of
the Women and Sports Commission
and what happened was a lot
of these new sports came on,
and nobody was
reminding them that you
have to have equal numbers
of women athletes and men
athletes.
And they didn't because
unfortunately, guys
were in charge again,
and guys do what they do.
They say OK, let's have
a lot more guys here.
Oh, women, let's
have some women.
These are new sports
so who's going
to notice that we have
twice as many men as women.
Well, after the fact I noticed.
So it's going to take us a
while to get back to equality
at the Olympic Winter Games
because of one set of games
where they put 20 men in and
only 10 women in the sport
of say, border cross.
You all know what
border cross is.
And I'm not making a
political comment on this.
It's a lot of fun.
You line up four skiers at the
top of essentially moguls hill
and they race to get across
to the finish line first,
often bumping into one
another along the way,
making it exciting to
see who will make it
to the finish line.
But that sport-- how many
women really why do that?
Well, I'll tell you.
A lot of women want to do that.
It's fun.
But not so many got the
chance at the games.
All right, now I do
have to hurry along.
The last games.
What we do at the IOC
is we pay attention.
You'll see here, if you can't
see it, that we pay attention
not only to the number
of athletes there,
but we pay attention to the
National Olympic Committees
and whether or not they have
women in their leadership.
Where they have
women, [INAUDIBLE] who
is the person in charge
of the team at the games,
where they have women as
flag bearers and where
they have accredited media.
We're looking at the
numbers because if you
watch the numbers,
you can see if things
are going that direction we
say we want them to go or not.
We are paying attention to
how the games are presented.
We're paying attention
to who gets to be there
and what their experiences
are at the games.
This has been a very
fast overview of a very--
complicated is not the right
word, but confusing might be.
The way the Olympic
movement is structured,
the International
Olympic Committee
owns the Olympic games.
We're the only ones
who can say, yes,
this is where the
Olympic games will be.
The IOC decides what sports
will be on the program,
but the International
Federations control the sports.
The National Olympic
Committees are the ones
who enter the athletes.
It's often said that
there's three pillars
of the Olympic movement.
Well, I think there
are four, and I
prefer the pyramid, which oddly
enough has four sides to it.
We think of a pyramid
and the triangle,
but it has four sides.
So I think the athletes
are a very essential part
of the Olympic movement.
We have to have athletes.
We have to have
International Federations.
We have to have National
Olympic Committees
and we have to have the
International Olympic
Committee, or sports would
exist, but the others would not
without the International
Olympic Committee.
I'm sure they'll be
lots of questions.
I've spoken a lot of Olympic
languages with alphabet soup
and I hope that you'll be
able to remember the questions
because you're going to hear
a lot more interesting things
than I have to offer.
Bottom line, we had Title IX.
How on earth did women get to
the starting lines in countries
throughout the world that
didn't have Title IX?
In part, the NCAA
helped that greatly
to get women to the line,
but it is really miraculous.
And through the determination of
other women like Alice Milliat,
who is a French woman who
in the 1920s made sure
that women had track and field.
They called it athletics.
track and Field, and she put on
track and field events that had
20,000 spectators, which
is why you see in 1928,
track and field coming onto the
Olympic program in the way it
should have back in the 1900's.
And with one minute and
22 seconds left, oops 20,
I will end my presentation.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- OK.
I'm going to stay here
and do my presentation
because you guys wouldn't be
able to see me over there.
So I'm kind of rounding
everything up and talking
about disability
and how disability
plays into who gets to play.
And I come at this from a couple
of different perspectives,
three different
perspectives actually,
as I go through my presentation.
So the first is kind a
landscape of where we
are with just disability sport.
I think it's really relevant
and important to talk about that
before I move onto
the gender piece,
because they intersect and
they do play into one another.
And I'll talk a little bit
about the role that gender plays
in disability sports,
and then wrap it up
with a current example
of this question of who
gets to play, where
do they get the play,
and what's the structure
around them getting to play.
All right, so, to start
out with where we are,
I'm not going to bore you
guys with too much relevant US
law and case law, but I
think the biggest thing
to understand with that is--
and I know Anita talks about
this a lot in her presentations
and what she believes as far
as sport being a human right,
and who's allowed to play.
Well, as you guys can see
through some of this US law
and case law, for
the longest time
it's been a privilege for
individuals with disabilities
to be able to play sport.
It has not been a right.
And so the only way that they've
been able to access sport,
that we have been
able to access sport,
is through law
that you see here.
Relevant US law,
Title IX, Rehab Act,
which Donna spoke about in
her presentation, the ADA.
And in relevant case law with
Casey Martin vs. the PGA,
McFadden vs. Cousins, which
is Tatiana McFadden, who's
a pretty well-known
female racer right now.
And so those are
the opportunities
that we have had to sort of
assert our right to play sport
and our right to get
to the line, basically.
That's how we as individuals
with disabilities
get to the starting
line, quite often,
is it has to be through
relevant case law.
The last two pieces, and more
importantly the last piece,
the OCR "Dear Colleague
Letter" of 2013,
that's been one of the
most important pieces
of clarification
and legislation that
moved our opportunity the
most for that I've seen,
in the past probably
10 to 15 years.
And basically, what that is was
a clarification of section 504
for the Rehab Act.
Stating that you do have
to provide extra curricular
opportunities for your
students with disabilities
in your schools.
And so it's a clarification
of that saying
this is what you have to do.
OK, so along with
that kind of privilege
by having to go
through case law,
and having to go
through US law, we
talk a lot about
who gets to make it
to international and
professional opportunities
to play sport.
On the left you have
able-bodied individuals.
They kind of have this
defined path of where you go.
Play at recreational
level, youth
sport level, scholastic,
intercollegiate, national,
international, professional.
It's a pretty linear progression
for able-bodied individuals
to get there.
On the right side, you have
people with a disability
and we have play and recreation
level to some extent.
That's more your
interscholastic level
where you have
opportunities for PE
or you have
opportunities outside
of school for those
extracurricular activities.
They're not completely
there right now.
They're moving in
the right direction,
but there is some
opportunity that exist there.
Youth and sport level,
there are youth sports
level opportunities for
kids with disabilities
to play sport, depending
upon the sport.
Scholastic, that's more
of your high school.
Not a lot of that exists
outside of special recreation
opportunities, special
recreation associations.
You don't see a
lot of students who
get to compete for
their high school.
You see it-- and this is where
some of that relevant case law
comes into play.
You get to see
it, on some level,
in individual sports
where students
have been awarded the right--
the right and the
privilege to be
able to compete on their
track teams and earn
points for their teams.
And they go to state and
national competitions,
or the right to
practice with them.
You see it in swimming a bit.
Where you see the hole
is in team competitions.
And later on in the
presentation I'll
talk a little bit about
that differentiation
and what that looks like.
Intercollegiate, another
huge hole exists.
Again, later on in
the presentation
I'll come back and
address that a little bit.
And then international
professional.
That's actually
far more developed
than we see at the national
intercollegiate level
with the Paralympic games,
with professional opportunities
to play sports, team
sports actually,
and the opportunity to be
professional swimmers, racers,
and that kind of thing
across the world.
So who makes it to here?
We can all make it
to there, but there's
significant gaps in our
ability to be able to play
at those different levels.
Just to kind of make this
tangible and show examples.
At the University
of Illinois we're
really fortunate to have
a pretty robust disability
support program.
And our student athletes achieve
at a very, very high level,
winning championships,
winning races.
What we think of as achieving
on the athletic side.
And our student athletes,
when they come back
from an international
competition,
winning, succeeding,
there's zero recognition.
There's zero support
from athletics
from my university
in the same way
that you would see their
able-bodied peers received at.
We have had teams that won
national championships.
We come back and it's just null.
Mentioning Tatiana
McFadden earlier.
Her legend is growing, and it's
getting bigger, and bigger,
and bigger.
And those of you
in the Boston area
will get to see that
in a couple of weeks.
But she was a student athlete on
our campus for a very long time
before she made this
transition into being
a professional athlete.
And the way I kind of
conceive and think of this
is who wouldn't want her to
represent their university?
Right?
And who wouldn't want any
of our student athletes
wearing Illinois, or wearing
Harvard, or wearing whatever
school that might be across
their chest because they're
such great representatives
of your university
or of your high school
where those gaps exists.
They train in the
exact same way.
They compete in
the exact same way.
That gap exists there and it's a
gap that we're looking to fill.
Just looking at-- based off
that last little chart, when
we talk about being
otherwise qualified
to participate in all of
these levels of competition,
what we're basically talking
about is skill and talent.
You meet certain criteria
of age, or of gender
or of classification level,
whatever it might be.
But then we have this
otherwise qualified caveat,
and that equals skill, and
it narrows as you get higher.
You have to have a higher
level skill as you get
higher and higher on the chart.
And for athletes
with disabilities,
you don't move up this chart
just because you're disabled.
You don't move up this
sort of progression
just because you
happen to be somebody
that has a disability
that live in this area.
You have to have skill.
It's an intentional way for
you to get to that point.
And so it's really important to
understand those two parallels
between how able-bodied
athletes rise to that pinnacle
and how athletes
with disabilities
rise to that pinnacle.
Just to kind of
touch on and go back
to the case law a
little bit, there
is a growing demand
for participation,
and that's the
question that we get
a lot is who's going to play?
Where's the critical mass?
Where are the athletes
that are demanding?
Well, it's there.
We kind of have our outliers of
people like Tatiana McFadden,
or when you look in
the Olympic games
with like a Natalie
Du Toit or somebody
like that, who has competed
with a disability at both
the Olympic and
Paralympic level.
You have these outliers,
and while they're
great to sort of start
the conversation,
they don't sustain.
Critical mass is what sustains
competition at a higher level,
and so there are
student athletes that
are demanding equal treatment
as varsity athletes, excuse me.
It's through those
administrative complaints
and lawsuits.
Athletes with
disabilities are going
to impact a greater demand
for similar opportunities
at the collegiate level, where
we're beginning to see that now
as we move forward.
And then I think as this
generation's coming up,
they're going to be more
expectant of equality,
and they're going to
know their rights,
know that this is not
a privilege for them to be
able to participate in sport.
It is their right.
This is kind of where
we start to move
a little bit into gender.
I'm going to talk a little
bit about what the needs
and barriers are with
athletes with disabilities,
but it's going to bleed a
little bit into gender because I
think the two are very similar.
I think that athletes
with disabilities
are almost following
a path where we've
seen women athletes come from.
No matter how it's
presented or couched,
discrimination towards
students of disability
is still discrimination.
And it's very similar to issues
surrounding race, gender,
sexual orientation.
So the process
that women athletes
had to go through during Title
IX to get access to sport,
our student athletes are
going through right now.
It's a very relevant time
for our student athletes.
We are often viewed as
not equal to our peers.
I see this every
single day on campus
at the University of
Illinois, and we are actually
seeing someone who is a
leader in this aspect,
but on a day to day basis,
I see the inequality
of what our student
athletes have to go through.
Small example, access to the
student athlete dining hall.
Something that
seems pretty simple.
Where student athletes
can go in, they
can grab food on their way
to class, after practice,
ability to recover,
our student athletes
don't have access
to that option.
They have to fend for meals
however they can fend for meals
to properly recover.
Small example, but
has a huge impact
across the board in what our
student athletes experience.
I think oldness and perceptions.
I think
That is probably the
single biggest barrier
to students with
disabilities right now.
Again, it goes back to that
similarity of women in sport.
Like what were the old
myths and stereotypes
that women had to deal with as
we spoke about earlier with.
It's not good, physically.
You're going to stop having
your menstrual cycle.
All of those things
that are there
based on myths and
stereotypes, you
encounter those with our student
athletes with disabilities.
So we see able-bodied
sport is the norm.
There is a diminished value of
sport and leisure activities
for people with disabilities.
There's lack of education and
expertise on what disability
sport is and who can play.
And there's a wide
range of individuals
of who can play disability
sport, and that kind of leads
into that next piece,
which is classification.
I'll come back to
that in a second.
So just the role
of gender and how
it combines with disability.
When we go back
and we look at what
those myths and stereotypes
are for gender, again--
sorry, with disability--
they bleed into gender.
So how does society attach
meaning to disability?
When we have an
image in our minds
of what someone
with a disability
looks like, what
they're able to do,
we have pretty low standards.
Or historically we've
had pretty low standards,
low expectations.
We don't expect
them to be physical.
We don't expect them to
expect physical activity.
We don't expect them to be able
to achieve on a high level.
We hold them to lower standards.
A lot of this evolves out of
the medical model of disability.
And I think in order to take
that next step with disability
sport, it's evolving into
more of a social model
with disability, and so
it's surrounded with pity.
You look at that person
with a disability
and you kind of feel sorry for
them that they can't do this
or can't do that.
And so what we try to do with
disability sport, and now
adding in gender
into it, we're trying
to flip that and attach
a different meaning
to disability.
So looking at the social
construction of sport,
that is also a
critical factor that
impacts perceptions related
to the participation of women
with physical
disabilities in sport.
Because now you have
these conceptions
of what individuals with
disability looks like,
what they're capable are,
now you add gender onto it
and you get that
double whammy effect.
And so someone who--
an individual with
a disability is
supposed to be frail, fragile,
weak, low expectations,
not being physical.
You confound that
now with a female who
is supposed to be weak, sit on
the sidelines, clap politely,
and you put those
two together, and you
create this rub between
what our expectations are,
and what reality can be, and
what we have the opportunity
to do.
So it leads to those
conflicting expectations.
We do have negative
perceptions and stereotypes.
I can't tell you how
many times that I've
heard it's so great
that you guys get
to get out and play
sport, and that's
just on the disability level.
Or as a female athlete, times
where my team was really good,
and we had to play against
men's teams, and some
of the derogatory terms that you
heard, telling you to get off
the court, telling you you're
not welcome against this team,
telling you they're
going to come back out
and beat up one
of your teammates.
Those were things that were just
realities as we moved forward
through this process.
Just to give a couple
of examples touching
on the Paralympic games.
So we had about
38% participation,
43% of medal events,
which was almost
a 10% increase from London.
So that's positive.
That piece is growing.
So that's kind of the
role that gender plays.
What I'm going to
do really quickly,
because I'm running
out of time, is
run through a real world example
of what's happening right now.
There's been a little bit of
slowed progress with this,
but those of you guys
on the east coast
know about the ECAC, a really
awesome athletic conference.
What they have done is they've
adopted an inclusive sport
model a couple of
years ago, and it's
based on principles
of inclusion depending
on a person's specific
disability, and their ability
to compete at a varsity level.
Otherwise qualified, right? ?
So as we kind of go through
of what inclusive sport
looks like, and this will be
a really quick run through,
the first couple of principals--
student athletes can
participate on existing teams
with either no accommodations
or some small accommodations
that don't effect the sport.
So if we look at--
that's Marla Runyan.
She's the first runner
there, blind athlete,
able to run without a guide.
Doesn't significantly
impact the sport.
We have Anthony Robles
here, who is a wrestler.
Won a division one national
title at Arizona State.
A swimmer here, competing
for her university.
So that does not
significantly alter sport.
You're not changing the sport.
Third principle,
inclusion of athletes
with a disability through the
addition of adapted events.
This is when you see track
and field athletes who compete
in our wheelchair divisions.
That's Tatiana McFadden.
The addition of
events with a guide
runner for amputees that
are separate events,
but you're still winning points,
so to say, at your events.
Swimming, there's rowing,
wheelchair tennis.
And then lastly,
it's the inclusion
of athletes with a disability
through the creation
of adapted team sports.
And this is kind of what I
was talking about earlier.
This is where the
donut hole exists.
This is where we don't do a
really great job right now
at the Scholastic level
of inclusion of athletes
with disabilities.
And so this is
wheelchair basketball.
It's kind of your
traditional team sports.
Sled hockey, sitting
volleyball, and goalball.
So that's a really
quick and dirty version
of where we are with
disability sport.
Where we've come from.
How it's been seen as a
privilege for individuals
with disabilities to be able
to participate in sport.
How that then
compounds with gender
and makes it even more
difficult to access with
added layers of discrimination
for women with disabilities.
And then where we can
be, and the future,
and where we can go
with disability sport
if we just think
outside of that model
that we have right
now for sport.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well, I would like
to commend my panelists
for coming in on time or
under time, and also giving us
so much to think about
just to start our day,
and that's really
what we had hoped
for when we're planning this.
I think what I'd like
to do is allow them
to step back and talk about
some big issues and some
of the themes that
have come through.
And I think the one
that really sticks out
for me is this idea of
sports as a birthright
that all humans
enjoy and then also
what are the
challenges women face
in claiming that birthright?
But I think, Anita, for
you especially, that's
your philosophy of sports.
- Yeah, for a long
time I believed that.
Maybe growing up with three
brothers and not understanding
why I couldn't get onto
the basketball court,
and I couldn't, I couldn't,
couldn't, couldn't.
It didn't make sense to me why
I did not have this access.
My parents were well evolved.
I could cut the grass and my
brothers could wash the dishes,
but there was this whole
area that disallowed me.
And it did not seem
fair and it wasn't fair
because all humans have this
desire to take part in sport.
It's the one thing
that we do as a species
that no other species does.
If you've heard me speak before
I reference the fact that
what other species sets up
hurdles and races across them
to see who gets across
the finish line first?
I referenced that I've seen
an ant climb onto a twig
to get across a puddle of water.
I've never seen them
line up those twigs
to get across a puddle of water.
It's something that
we enjoy doing.
We enjoy talking about it.
We enjoy taking part in sport.
We enjoy the history of it.
It brings us together
as communities.
It helps us enjoy
people's success.
It helps us get into that
zone of excellence, which
I think we need to study more.
But it's something
that we do as humans
and it's not just some humans.
It's not just one
half of humanity.
It's all of humans.
- I completely agree and
I, again, I look at this
through the lens of disability.
And it's something,
like I mentioned,
where it's seen as
individuals with disabilities,
that they don't have
the desire to compete.
They don't have the desire
to challenge themselves
at that high level, and
that's just completely untrue.
I think if you look
across the board,
internationally, there are
no barriers in place over
and over again that
show those individuals
that it is a privilege.
It addresses that
larger question
of what bodies
are able, and what
bodies do we see as able,
and from a gender perspective
and from a disability
perspective.
And what bodies have the right
to be able to participate.
So I completely agree with that.
And it's important that
we, as much as we can,
remove those systemic barriers.
That's what creates
sport as a privilege,
is that there's those
systemic barriers in place
of saying who can play and who
can get to that starting line.
And so it's kind of
on us and everybody
here to begin to remove
those and re-conceptualize,
especially-- again, I come from
the disability sport angle.
Re-conceptualize
what that looks like.
Re-conceptualize what sport
looks like, and what bodies
that can compete look like,
and how it's their right.
- I think we're speaking
to the choir in terms
of our birthright.
Seriously, no child should ever
be told that you cannot pursue
your dreams.
I don't care whether it's sport,
or being an engineer, or a fire
person, or any of it.
I think we're all in that mode.
But if the right
has been denied,
then I think we have
to jump into can
we change the legal system
to make sure it's a right?
And that's what was
done with Title IX.
I thought it was very
interesting in Stephanie's
presentation, you can
see the Dear Colleague
letter on disability did
not come out until 2014.
And that's the equivalent
of the regulation
that got done before Title
IX was even in place.
And I could kick myself having
been with the Women's Sports
Foundation in not
embracing the need,
in the case of
disabled sport, to go
after those same regulations
under disability.
No excuse.
Fortunately, Terri Lakowski
from the foundation
was very helpful in that
Dear Colleague letter.
But if McFadden never called
the Women's Sports Foundation,
Terri wouldn't have been there.
That Dear Colleague letter
wouldn't have been there.
We've got to make
this legal thing
and I have a question for Anita.
Is it true that in the
rest of the world, when
you look at our
experience with Title IX,
we have a legal right that
is actionable in the courts,
where in the rest of the
world, most countries take
civil rights and throw
them under a Civil Rights
Commission that is not as strong
an enforcement body as courts?
Is that accurate to say?
Or does anybody in
the audience who's
a lawyer want to come in on--
- My answer would be possibly.
- Because that's what
happened in Canada.
When our American
women challenged
the use of artificial
turf for World Cup--
- Soccer, football.
- In Canada, they
don't have a right
to pursue civil rights
actions in the courts.
It's a Civil Rights Commission
that's a weak sister.
So that would have been
the place to do it,
you now what I mean?
- But they have a
different system
because sports is a
part of the government,
unlike the system in
the United States.
So they have other
avenues to take action.
- It's an interesting place.
- We still haven't
signed [INAUDIBLE] yet.
- Yeah.
- I'm a historian, and I at one
point had looked to see whether
there was anything equivalent
to Title IX, globally,
and there wasn't.
There does seem to be, through
the various United Nations
commissions on women in
International Women's Year,
the topic began to
get on the agenda.
And it seems that the break out
decade for the United States
was the 70s.
I think, globally,
the breakout decade
was the 90s, when
things really started
to pop in terms of gender.
And I think that the UN
had a lot to do with that.
But I think this
raises another question
I wanted us to weigh in on
because it's relevant really
to what we're doing
the rest of the day.
The United States
sports system is not
the way sport is organized
in the rest of the world.
And I know we have a
very literate audience,
but I thought we
should maybe explore
some of the ways in which
the situation we kind of take
for granted is not necessarily
how sport is organized starting
with state support for sports.
So I don't know which of you--
- Let me just say this
one piece of the puzzle
and I think that's a
very important point.
Because we're one of the
few countries in the world
by to embed sport within
educational systems,
and because
education is a right,
our legal system
followed that thinking.
And what Congress really did
was as part of the Education
Amendments Act, as a condition
of higher education funding,
it attached this right
to education to sport.
We're the only place
in the world, I think,
that does that because
everything else is
clubs outside of the
educational system.
- Well, in Europe,
there's a have a right
to work part to it.
Sports are protected, but only
once you get to the point where
it your advocation--
your vocation, not advocation.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- I think for us, for
athletes of disabilities,
I think our process is directly
tied to the education process.
Physical activity is a part
of the education process
of children with disabilities
that has been largely ignored.
And I can speak from
personal experience
on that as far as physical
education opportunities
within school and
then opportunities
outside of school for
recreational opportunities.
And so that's been
the big push, is
the tie to education for
individuals with disabilities.
They're missing this huge piece
of their right to be educated.
And then the other
side of that too
is we see the education process
of the larger population
or public of that school.
Because we have such
that ingrained picture
of what an individual with a
disability looks like and what
they can do.
And so when you take that
individual for someone
who sits on the sidelines
at PE, they keep score.
They're the goalie that
just sits in the goal
and they don't do anything.
When you take them and you
move them from that position,
and you put them into a
position where they're active,
and they're actively giving
to that social environment,
it completely
changes the paradigm
and the lens through
which you see that person.
So it educates the rest of
the class, or the school,
or whatever it might be.
And so it's tied to
the educational process
in two really big
ways, which makes it--
that's that educational
right of everyone.
- I think I have one more
question for the panel
before I open it up.
It really came to
me this morning
and I was thinking that
here I have three women who
have been able, or are in the
process, of making a career out
of being in the world of sports.
And I think that is
something we should mark
and it didn't used to happen.
But I wondered,
since you all have
been able to really
do that, if you
had had any advice for people
as they're contemplating
a career in this area.
I mean, we've
certainly given them
plenty of reasons to realize
why it needs to be done,
but if there is anything
you wanted to pass along.
- Well, you know [INAUDIBLE].
I think the barriers
to women in sport right
now are the male
dominance of men.
This whole issue of
homologous reproduction
where the current
white male power
structure is in the process
of reproducing itself,
not necessarily
intentionally, but we
hire people who look like us.
We hire people who
are comfortable
and this is a systems problem.
We have to have schools and
support organizations that
follow systems that
prevent discrimination
in terms of hiring, and
that means search committees
that are a minority dominated.
That means not one
of your finalists
being a minority person,
it means at least 30%.
Research shows at least
30% of that finalist pool
has to be an under-represented
minority in order
for this change to take place.
We've got to hit all those
spots and we have not
done that in terms of this
organizational system that
has to be put in place.
- One thing I would say
is I didn't listen to--
I had a couple of opportunities.
So I've been fortunate to coach
at the international level,
both at the junior and
senior national team level.
And at the Paralympic games
last year, I was the--
for wheelchair basketball,
I was the only female
with a disability that was
the head coach of a wheelchair
basketball team, and that's
just unacceptable in our sport.
And the path to get
there was challenging.
My first international
coaching job
I actually gotten a roundabout
way with a male being
selected to do the job who was
significantly under qualified.
I was his assistant coach.
He quit.
Now he's moved up to the
head coaching position.
And when I was starting
to think that coaching
the senior national
team was going
to be where I wanted
my career to go,
our high performance
director at the time
told me that I needed
take an opportunity
to be an assistant coach with
our men's junior national team
first.
And I was like, nah,
that doesn't sound right,
and that's not
what I want to do.
I want to make sure
that I'm continuing
on this path with coaching
women and empowering women,
and I don't need
to take that step
over in what he saw was a
step up, this lateral step,
to make myself look better.
There's no way.
And so I think for me it
was I had the strength
to stick to my guns in that way,
and know the path that I wanted
to be on, and who I
wanted to influence,
and where I wanted to go.
Fortunately, I was
able to overcome that,
but what always sticks in
my mind in my conversation
with him is he told
me-- he's like you know,
you came into that junior
national team coaching job
through the back door.
And I'm like, you have
got to be kidding me.
You have to be kidding me like.
I outright earned that job.
And so that always
sticks with me
in that process of
just really critically
thinking about the opportunity
that's in front of you
and knowing if that's
really going to get you
where you want to be.
And if what this person
who is a-- and he
was a white, able-bodied
male, what he was telling me
I needed to do in
order to achieve
what I wanted to achieve.
And so that's something
that's always stuck with me,
and I try to tell
that to anybody
that I talk to, female
with a disability,
without a disability, whatever.
Is just that you kind of have
to know where you're going
and have an idea of it, and know
that what someone is telling
you that's a move up,
if it's not a move up,
if it doesn't vibe with
what your passion is,
and where you want to go.
So that would be the
advice that I have.
- I want to agree
with Stephanie.
Naivety is a great thing.
- Oh, I was super naive.
I was young and super naive.
- So was I when I went to
the University of Texas
as the first Director
of Women's Athletics.
I really thought Texas wanted
a National Championship
Program and that's what
I was supposed to do.
And so I was a 29-year-old naive
person, but I acted that way,
and I didn't know any
better, which is good.
And I think the
other thing is do not
go through this mental process
of I have to be qualified.
No male ever did that for a job.
Ever.
[APPLAUSE]
You are probably more educated
than your male counterpart
and there's no job
that you can't learn
and so you might as well just
go after what it is you want.
You're going to be better
than 90% of the population.
- I think one more thing to
add-- sorry, really quickly--
that I think is
really important,
and something I had to
learn through my naivety,
was that it's really
important to have
a strong team around you.
And I have been really fortunate
to have a lot of great mentors
throughout my career.
And one of the things I
was really hesitant to do
was reach out, and reach out to
people for advice and support.
I thought that was kind
of a brown nosing thing
or I just had a really
negative conception
of what that whole
networking piece looked like.
But it's so important that
you find people, and surround
yourself with people who
have been on that path,
and who can help guide
you through that journey.
I wouldn't be
anywhere near where
I am without those people
significantly influencing me.
So ask, reach out, a
lot of times people
are more than happy to help.
We might think that they're
not and they're too busy,
or they had this going on,
that's totally not true.
- I think, with that, I'd like
to open it up to questions.
And those of you who have
been to other conferences
know the drill, but maybe
some of you are new to it.
There's a microphone in
the middle of the aisle.
We ask you to come up,
to identify yourself,
and to frame it as a question.
You're welcome to frame
it to the whole panel
or to a specific panelist,
not to go into a comment,
and that way we can get as
many questions in as possible.
So if you'll start, please.
- Hi, I'm Elizabeth
Guggenheimer and when
the 2012 women's
Olympic team came back
or when they were
competing, I thought
this is going to bust
that stereotype of women
not being competitive.
And then the 2016 Olympics
team, the women right, they
outshined the men,
and somehow I think
the question of women being
competitive is kind of still
out there.
And the other thing that
goes with this idea that
being collaborative means
you can't be competitive.
And the most
dramatic illustration
of this that I
saw, collaborative
plus competitive,
was last Sunday,
the Oxford and
Cambridge boat race
that the Cambridge women, when
they won and they were just
joyous, collaborative,
they didn't look exhausted,
and yet they were full
of the joys of having
been competitive.
So I just wonder if we can
get through that stereotype.
I'd love to hear her thoughts.
- OK it's a rowing event.
[CHUCKLES]
- Yes, it's yours, Anita.
- Mine.
And rowing was the very
first intercollegiate sport
where Yale and Harvard lined
up, lo, those many years ago--
1852-- to compete and
it's continued since then.
Collaborative, the
sport of ruling is the--
I call it the
ultimate team sport.
you have to collaborate.
You can't say I'll be back in a
couple of strokes and help out.
See you then.
It's a team sport, and yet it's
called an individual sport,
oddly enough.
There's so many confusions.
How can you not be competitive
driving someplace today.
How can you not be competitive?
For example, you want
to get that space,
and there's a car
in front of you,
and you know they're
going to get the space.
Life is about competition
in so many ways,
and for an individual not
to be able to compete,
is to have to not be
prepared for today's society.
I mean, there were terrible
things being told to me.
I had no idea that
when I started college
that I was going to embark
upon a college sports
where it was not supposed
to be competitive,
because after all, we're
supposed to be young ladies,
and competition
is something bad.
It just never occurred
to me that that
would be the type of
collegiate experience
that was being offered
to women at that time.
When and where you're
born is so important
and the time was just right
because things were changing.
I don't know how many of you
are a part of that era where
competition was bad.
You were supposed to learn
skills, that was good,
but that was enough.
It's just a terrible
thing to do to tell people
that you can learn a skill,
but never put it into action
and test it.
- I think we live in a-- so the
first part of that question,
we live in a media culture
and the control of what gets
on television does not rest
with those who are enthusiastic
about women's sports, especially
here in the United States.
And as a result,
it's this dilemma
that you so aptly expressed.
Once every four years we see
this bright light of talent
and then it disappears.
And society places a value
on the amount of exposure
and who they see.
And so when did
women disappear, they
must not have quality staying
power in terms of athletes.
It's some terrible
kind of a conclusion.
And until our
digital environment
enables us to catch
up on television--
our media platforms are
such that they're not
under the control of the people
that they're under control
right now, I'm not
sure that we're going
to make a change like that.
Domestic television right now is
dominated by the big four men's
sports and each of
our major distributors
have overpaid for that product.
And they're so busy now using
every promotional minute,
every two hours before the
game, two hours after the game,
every predictable
time and place,
trying to recapture that money,
that there are no media rights
fees for women's sports
in the United States.
Do you see a solution other than
a digital solution [INAUDIBLE]
television.
- Right now, the IOC is
working on having a channel,
and it's stepped all over the
US because without the US,
it's going to work.
And the deal was made for NBC
to have the actual channel
in the United States, which
could limit the US Olympic
team's ability to raise
funds, but we'll see.
We don't know if
it's going to work
because we've been taught--
to point out-- we've been
taught to just wait a while,
and then the games
will come, and you
get force fed for
two weeks, and then
you have to starve for the
next four years, or two years,
until the next forced
feeling comes along.
And that was Dick
Ebersol's approach
to making the games
more valuable,
but also we are denied the
stories of these athletes
around the world.
Euro sport did the opposite.
They taught you who the athletes
were so you could follow them,
and then came the
Olympic games, you
could understand the path that
they had taken to get there.
So please look at
the Olympic channel.
It's digital now.
I think it comes onto
a channel platform
and by July, if not sooner, NBC.
- Let's move on to
another question.
- Well, actually I was going
to-- my name is Jane Regan.
I'm a journalist.
But I don't do
sports journalism,
that's one reason I came.
I also teach journalism
and my question
is exactly related to Donna's
comment and the other comments.
I'm wondering if in the
women's sports world,
maybe in the journalism world,
or sports journalism world,
are there pressure groups,
or associations, or movements
to put pressures on
the news organizations
and the newsrooms to include,
and to go out and recruit,
and include more female
journalists, and sports
journalists.
Because certainly,
there are movements
that have not been
that successful,
and it goes up and down,
but of journalists of color.
There is than non-journalists
and editors and stuff of color,
feel it acutely, the
whiteness of their newsrooms.
And so there are great
proactive activities
that the bigger
media outlets do,
that the bigger universities
do to recruit, and promote,
and encourage
journalists of color.
I'm wondering if you know of,
or if we could all take part in
somehow, something similar
for female sports journalists.
Because I agree that
our society is so
influenced what's on the box,
or on the tablet, or whatever,
and it's all-male sports, except
for once every four years.
So that's my question
and provocation.
- There are organization
[INAUDIBLE] Women in Sports
and Entertainment is one
such group that promotes
women's sport journalism.
- Association for Women
in the Sports Media.
- There are some
groups out there.
- I despair because now
there's such direct access
through the digital world.
I can't do it all,
I wish I could.
I don't understand
why we're not doing
more of telling the stories
and telling it directly.
But we're not,
and I don't why, I
guess because everybody's busy.
But it seems logically that once
the world opened up for people
to be able to directly
communicate, and to have
networking, and be able to
get the information out there,
that it would.
- In terms of putting advocacy
pressure on the system,
it will also start with data.
And I have to applaud
AP, Associated Press,
for at least starting to keep
a report card on sports editors
and--
- Guidelines.
- Who is in our system
and I think we just
have to do more of that.
And TIDES, Dick Lapchick's
group in Florida,
keeps it to an
extent, but I think
we have to get more data
about the discrepancies,
and that is going
to ignite advocacy.
Hopefully that's the path.
- I think that really is
a challenge to all of us
to really always be counting.
Counting how many women,
how many people of color,
how many people with
disabilities, because if you
don't, and then
demanding that it
changed-- because
if you don't, it
reverts to white male control.
And I think that what we have
to avoid is a sense of well,
nobody in this room
is smug or satisfied,
but if you just sort of accept
it as business as usual,
the progress is going to stop.
It may not backslide
all that far back,
but you have to just
keep staying vigilant.
And all the things that we're
saying-- here it is, 2017,
and we're still
raising these issues.
And I think we just have
to stay on top of it
because the problem is
there and it's deep.
- Just one more point on that.
I think one of the great
things that has happened--
the only great thing that
has happened in terms
of Trump's election is--
no, seriously.
We have finally had a
catalyst from moving
from identity politics to
all for one and one for all.
And you're seeing that
at the grassroots level
now that if you can
give me the data
point, if you can
give me a reason,
everybody is going to help me.
Now do this.
That has not existed before.
We've stayed in a Black
Lives Matter silo.
We've stayed in a woman's silo.
And now I'm seeing
something I've never
seen before in terms of
a lot of people jumping
into issues that aren't theirs.
- Another question.
- Hi, my name is Karen Flynn.
I'm from the Harvard
summer school.
I have a question about how--
or I wanted to see if the
panelists could comment
on how sports are organized
by gender, just fundamentally,
and whether you can see
that potentially changing
in the future.
In other words,
whether there could
be an opportunity for girls
to play against girls,
and women to play against women,
but also to try to break down
that complete
separation by gender
that exists in sports
because I think
that that separation,
in itself, underscores
a sense of inferiority
about women in sports.
So can you see potential
in future decades
for that to change?
- Stephanie, do you
want to talk to that?
Because in some ways
I think your model--
- Sure.
In a lot of disability sport,
we do that out of necessity
initially because just
with the critical mass.
And so I can speak from
a wheelchair basketball
perspective, where we
have teams that are coed,
or teams that compete either--
I've played on
full women's teams
that compete against
full men's teams.
One of the ways that our
organization incorrectly,
I think, tries to--
they call it, "accommodate"
for that, and without getting
into a sort of a long
discussion about our sport,
with wheelchair basketball
you have a wide range
of disabilities that can play.
And so in order to
level the playing field,
you have this classification
system based on that,
and you're seeing a point value.
And one of the ways,
globally and in the US that--
and I think it actually does
a complete disservice to women
athletes within our sport,
is if you're rated as a 2.5,
then if you play on a men's
team, you go one point down.
It's absurd, absolutely absurd.
So I think we're kind
of already doing it.
We don't do it in
the most perfect way,
I don't think, because if we do
have women included on teams,
they're treated as of lower
value, and in essence,
sometimes become like
pylons on the court.
They're just there to be there.
So while we do this
out of necessity,
I don't think we do it
very well right now.
I think in order for
disability sport to grow,
I think there's going to have to
be coeducational opportunities
just because there
isn't the critical mass.
And while it might
address what you
were talking about with
the inferiority of women,
I think it has to be
done in the right way.
And I think that
classification example for us
is a way that it's not
being done in the right way.
I would much rather see them
play at whatever classification
they are, they hold
value, they bring
what they bring to the team,
and then it's a non issue then
at that point.
So we're sort of
there right now.
- We had that very interesting
discussion when we're
redrafting the Olympic Charter.
And I was the only woman in
the room among attorneys,
and we're talking
about equality,
and so the other guy, well,
you know, women and men,
they're not equal.
And I said, what do you mean?
And they said,
well, you know, they
have the heavyweight
boxing gold medal,
and then they have the feather
weight boxing gold medal,
and you would never
put a feather weight
against a heavyweight.
I said, no, of course not.
And so that's not equal, I
said, but are the medals gold?
Are they the same medals?
The same champions?
And he said, well,
yeah [INAUDIBLE]
Listen guys, men and
women are different,
and thank goodness
for the difference,
but can anyone in
this room tell me
that we are not absolutely
unequivocally and forever
equally human?
That's what we're talking about.
We are equally
human and therefore
once you go from there, you
stay on a level playing field
with respect and treating
people with respect.
And that's how we got sex
back into the Olympic Charter.
- We do a great job in
intramural in doing this
because we specify how
many men and how many
women are on the same
team, and in many cases,
don't make any other
rules adjustments at all.
In some cases we do,
but we have to change
the rules of these
sports that have
become cultural
rituals, which is what
makes it so difficult to do.
We know how to do it, but
the willingness isn't there.
- Hi, I'm Lily Judan, a
senior at the college,
and I had a question about
the role of female athletes
as advocates.
And my question is, is it fair
to ask all female athletes
to advocate for their sex?
Or is there also a role
for female athletes
just to be athletes
and play without having
to worry about what their
sex brings to the table?
- That's a great question.
- Take athlete out of it.
Do-- what's her name?
- I can't remember.
- She's walking away.
- She's out of here.
- So the point is, in the face
of looking at wrong, if you
stay silent, are you complicit?
- Exactly.
- So if you see wrong, do
you have a responsibility
to advocate, at least
to say it's wrong?
- My question's relevant.
I'm Sara [INAUDIBLE]
I'm a staff member here,
also a graduate of the college
and the softball program,
and I'm actually curious about
in your different context,
the role of male athletes
in this equation.
And I think the US men's
hockey team made a statement
about the women's plight.
I couldn't help but wonder,
what if Federer had refused
to take more money than Serena?
So I'm curious what you think in
terms of outlook in the future,
where do male athletes
fit into that equation?
- I have great hope.
I really do because we're
seeing the first generation
of male athletes who are willing
to buck their coaches power
and the power of the institution
at great personal risk.
We haven't seen that before.
We're looking at the
beginnings of unionization
among college athletes.
We are now talking about the
right of athletes to speak.
We're now talking about
the right of athletes
not to be controlled
by coaches, in terms
of what they put on Facebook, or
what they put in their Twitter
account.
That's a new conversation,
a really new conversation.
So I'm very hopeful
in that regard.
- Well, I think in
disability sport
you kind of have an
interesting intersection
with disability and gender.
And so quite often when
you look at male athletes
with disabilities,
a lot of times
their fight is coming
from the disability angle
and they don't bring
gender in with it.
And so I know we struggle
a little bit with that,
just to make sure that that
intersection is understood.
And that kind of
like Donna mentioned,
we can't stay in our
silo in those moments.
And so if you're
fighting for your right
to be able to go compete
as a disabled athlete,
then it has to be all
disabled athletes.
It can't just be fighting
for the men or vice versa.
So I think for us, it's
kind of getting over
that step of just fighting
it or just advocating
in your one silo.
It has to be an across
the board fight.
- Yeah, there's a
group called RISE,
and I don't know what
it all stands for,
but they're working
with athletes
to help them decide to make the
decision of whether to speak
up, and what risks that
they face with speaking
up, and helping them understand
that the risk of not speaking
up is you go for decades
and years wishing you had,
and figuring out how to
balance those things.
Because when you speak up, and
you might find that suddenly
you're not being given
the same amount of time
on the field of
play, and you have--
the coach-athlete dynamic
is a powerful one,
which needs a lot more
exploration as well.
Enough said.
- I say this to young
people all the time.
That if you feel because of
your personality or your lack
of even experience
in speaking out,
that it's not something that's
going to sit well with you,
find somebody who can.
Is there a tenured
female faculty member
who can make your case?
Is there somebody else on your
team that you can work with?
You could be the researcher.
You could be the
one that gathers
the ammunition and starts
planning what should be said.
You don't have to actually
absolutely say it,
you just have to make
sure it gets said.
- I think we're pretty
much out of time.
And what I would
like us all to do
is to thank our
panelists for getting--
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Nice job.